[Music]
earlier this week Council held its
monthly meeting for April with the draft
long-term plan currently in public
consultation it's a busy time for
council and there was a large agenda to
get through the council works closely
with team night or who DD Runanga on
many significant issues around our
district a proposal was made that a seat
with voting rights be made available on
the district planning and regulation
committee an order that the Runanga
could contribute to a review of the
Waimakariri district plan although this
motion was narrowly defeated the council
will continue to look at ways that can
partner with night oooh-ahhh her duty to
develop her district council appointed
councilors atkinson meyer and duty to
the hearing and deliberations panel for
the review of the local alcohol policy
and the hearing and deliberations panel
for the liquor banned by law review
these hearings are scheduled to take
place over July
the council also formally adopted the
final way mecha DD district development
strategy our district our future why
make it 80/20 48 this document was
presented to the community last year for
feedback and will help guide our growing
district's development over the next 30
years
counselors also had to consider a number
of complex water and wastewater
infrastructure issues and as a result
brought forward funding for improving
wastewater services in the ture he we
area brought forward funding and
approved the staff proceeding with
physical works on the upgrade of the
Oxford rule number one water scheme
while waiting for a resource consent to
be granted and approved a new budget for
drainage work and Springbrook in order
to mitigate flooding
the counselors also plan for the
upcoming Anzac Day commemorations and
they will attend the following services
across the district
[Music]
the next monthly council meeting will be
at the council chambers and Rangi Ora on
Tuesday 1st of May at 1 p.m.
[Music]